Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres nous avons l'impression que
les théories du complot sont une
invention récente qu'elles sont de notre
époque à nous et en effet quand on voit
le mouvement qua non aux États-Unis qui
suspecte un complot pédo satanique dans
l'état profond américain ou quand on
voit les antivacs qui sont persuadés
qu'on leur injecte une puce 5G en même
temps que le vaccin covid on se on se
conforte dans cette opinion c'est vrai
que l'époque contemporaine notre époque
de amplifie ces théories du complot
notamment avec la puissance des réseaux
sociaux mais ça n'est pas du tout une
invention récente c'est un phénomène
très ancien et c'est cela dont nous
allons parler ce soir dans cette
émission spéciale consacrée au prix du
livre d'histoire du Sénat émission que
nous avons intitulé Histoire du
complotisme
Jean-Noël Genet bonsoir bonsoir
Jean-Noël vous êtes un historien vous
avez enseigné longtemps à Sciences Po
vous êtes un spécialiste de l'histoire
culturelle et l'histoire des médias mais
vous avez aussi présidé le président
nationale de France président des radios
France vous avez été ministre de la
Communication je suis certain que
j'oublie dans votre biographie brillante
des éléments
vous avez publié une cinquantaine
d'ouvrages vous avez et vous animer et
vous produisez une excellente émission
d'histoire que j'écoute religieusement
le samedi matin sur France Culture mais
là
vous êtes ici en qualité de président du
jury du Prix du livre d'histoire du
Sénat c'est en cette qualité que nous
avons l'honneur et le plaisir de vous
recevoir
rappelez-nous d'abord si vous le voulez
bien quel est ce prix comment est
composé son jury et surtout quelle est
sa vocation il a été fondé Wassim une
vingtaine d'années à l'initiative du
président Poncelet à l'époque président
du Sénat de alaméa son collaborateur il
est destiné à honorer des livres qui
répondent à trois critères tout en étant
présentatif bien sûr de les vitalité de
l'école historique française le premier
critère c'est d'être très lisible d'être
accessible à large public ce ne sont pas
des ouvrages faits par des historiens
pour les historiens
l'autre donnée majeur c'est que ils
doivent
apporter du nouveau c'est-à-dire se
fonder sur des recherches assidus
approfondies pour que ce soit pas
simplement ce peut être honorable
nouvelle mouture de choses déjà su et
puis enfin il faut que cela serve un
propos civique
sans que soit en rien pédagogique ou que
ce soit ça impose je ne sais quel que
l'idée reçue sur ce qu'il faut faire
dans une démocratie mais que on apporte
par ce livre des
occasions de réflexion et très souvent
évidemment il faut du recul parce que
l'histoire c'est la profondeur de champ
qui permet précisément de classer
quelque peu au service de la démocratie
se bombardement de nouvelles dont nous
sommes jour après jour les objets alors
vu de votre de ce poste de l'observation
mais de ce que vous occupez par ailleurs
comment voyez-vous l'évolution de votre
discipline de la discipline historique
j'ai l'impression peut-être que je me
trompe que le fossé qui existait entre
l'histoire classique et événementielle
et la nouvelle histoire plutôt attachée
au temps long aux mentalités que ce
fossé c'est peu à peu combler est-ce que
je me trompe non ne vous trompez pas
quand je considère l'évolution de
l'historiographie depuis une trentaine
d'années ou quarantaine d'années je suis
frappé par un certain nombre d'éléments
d'abord le développement de l'histoire
culturelle les représentations
qui est venu enrichir grandement
l'histoire politique traditionnelle
d'autre part vous n'avez pas tort d'y
assister l'intérêt de nouveau porté aux
événements le retour de l'événement
événement monstre avait dit un jour
Pierre Nora car nous avons appris que
tout événement toute conjoncture ne
parle pas seulement d'elle-même mais
qu'elle parle de tout un feuilleté de
temporalité qui viennent se concentrer à
un moment particulier par conséquent on
peut en tirer en tirer beaucoup de
choses et puis et puis il y a les
questions d'aujourd'hui c'est tout à
fait naturel que chaque génération pose
au passé des interrogations spécifiques
par exemple la question de la place des
femmes dans la société on a vu fleurir
toute une série de travaux y compris
pour la préhistoire qui concerne la
place de la femme de la société on
pourrait prendre d'autres exemples je
terminerai cette observation en disant
que je suis frappé par par la vitalité
par la qualité de l'école
historiographique française certains
esprits bougondisent que c'était mieux
avant
c'est une faribole là où je suis
c'est-à-dire dans ce poste d'observation
du du prix du livre d'histoire du Sénat
on nous voyons arriver les 250 livres
importants paru dans l'année ou bien
dans l'émission vous avez bien voulu
évoquer c'est à dire qu'on va se
détendre ou j'habite beaucoup de jeunes
historiens alors là je suis vraiment
frappé par oui par la diversité des
curiosités qui ne prennent pas du tout
d'ailleurs de distance par rapport aux
règles anciennes du métier c'est à dire
l'accès aux archives l'accès concret aux
réalités et un effort constant chez la
plupart pour aller contre leur préjugés
initiaux quand il se confrontent à des
réalités complexes le suspense c'est
assez dur il faut qu'on révèle
maintenant le livre que vous avez
distingué j'imagine qu'il s'inscrit dans
la perspective que vous venez d'évoquer
alors dites nous quel est ce livre et
pourquoi vous l'avez choisi c'est le 21e
promet le 21e historien ou historienne
que nous nous avons choisi de célébrer
avec ce jury éminent d'une douzaine
d'historiens et d'autres personnalités
ce livre c'est celui-ci c'est les livres
de Pierre-Yves Beaurepaire qui s'appelle
les Illuminati de la société secrète aux
théories du complot il répond exactement
aux trois critères que j'évoquais il y a
un instant c'est nouveau c'est
approfondi c'est clair et c'est civique
très bien alors Pierre-Yves Beaurepaire
bonsoir
vous êtes professeur à l'université Côte
d'Azur vous êtes membre de l'Institut
universitaire de France j'avais publié
une quinzaine d'ouvrages principalement
autour de l'époque des Lumières mais
vous êtes beaucoup intéressé aussi à la
franc-maçonnerie et donc vous publiez
Jean-Noël vient de le dire les
Illuminatis chez Taillandier au départ
de du mythe il y a une véritable
histoire il y a une véritable société
secrète en Bavière à la fin du 18e
siècle qui a d'ailleurs une histoire
brève tout à fait c'est une histoire de
10 ans entre 1776 et puis 1785 alors que
le mythe lui se
déploie et prospère depuis 200 ans donc
c'est ce livre c'est une sorte
d'histoire à part égale entre l'histoire
de la fin des lumières et puis le mythe
et aussi comme je l'ai dit dans
l'introduction c'est l'oper
contemporaine parce que c'est la matrice
du complotisme contemporain quand on
évoqué il y a quelques années le les
élections américaines et Trump qui
annonçaient se faire voler les élections
là sa rédaction alors qu'elle n'avait
même pas encore débuté et bien dans le
livre je montre qu'en 1798 deux ans
avant l'élection présidentielle
américaine de 1800 on dit déjà dans
l'entourage du président sortant donc le
parallèle est évident John Adams que
Thomas Jefferson et l'homme des
illuminatis aux États-Unis qui va voler
l'élection donc il y a une société
secrète elle est inspirée par disons
vous vous désignez comme ça par une
vision radicale des lumières elle a un
projet subversif
elle est fabriquée un peu sur le modèle
de la franc-maçonnerie dans un syndrome
de ses membres sont
issus mais elle est aussi fabriquée
comme l'organisation quel combat c'est à
dire la Compagnie de Jésus qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette radicalité des lumières
qu'elle exprime et quel est son projet
subversif l'idée c'est à la fois
revisiter l'Antiquité dans une péripétie
aussi bien initiatique que des mystères
les mystères de l'usis fondaient une
sorte d'utopie pédagogique et en même
temps transformer
fondamentalement la société parce que on
se dit que il y a pas de vision
théologique des choses avec la
révolution qui va arriver mais n'empêche
quand même ils sont sensibles aux
tensions crispation et il se disent
qu'il faut revoir complètement la
formation des élites et c'est ça qui
donne la dimension
subversive à la société le fondateur
choisi comme danse Spartacus ça en dit
long parce que l'idée c'est de rompre
avec l'ancien régime bon cette société
va disparaître
et puis peu à peu le mythe va apparaître
et il est notamment il apparaît
notamment au moment de la Révolution
française disons au moment où on
s'inquiète des effets de la Révolution
française en France au Royaume-Uni aux
États-Unis et c'est là qu'apparaît le le
la théorie conspirationnisme des
Illuminati tout à fait c'est à dire
qu'en fait il s'arrête comme je vous
l'ai dit 10 ans après leur fondation et
là il y a déjà quelque chose de tout à
fait neuf on leur fait un procès
politique on fait des descentes de
police on trouve des archives on publie
des noms y compris de ministres de
princes qui en sont membres mais la
révolution arrive et puis les
révolutions à l'époque sont vraiment des
révolutions européennes et atlantiques
donc déboussoles tout le monde et on
essaie de comprendre finalement ce qui
peut expliquer
l'incompréhensible et souvent dans ce
cas là comme on dirait aujourd'hui le
narratif proposé par ceux qui disent la
révolution n'a pu être le fruit que
d'une conspiration et bien
on va inventer en France les Illuminés
de Bavière c'est la baie baruelle en
ancien Jésuite qui prend sa revanche et
au même moment dans les îles
britanniques un savant écossais John
Robinson va lui forger le terme
Illuminati et il va dire en plus j'ai la
preuve de la conspiration des
illuminatisés l'invention finalement
d'un mot d'un nom et d'une conspiration
il dit pauvre ça fait comme Spirit et
aussitôt on se saisit de son livre pour
en faire une loi à la Chambre des
communes c'est-à-dire qu'on voit comment
là aussi ces interprétations
conspirationnistes
elles ont un effet de levier immédiat
sur la vie politique aussi bien en
Amérique quelques semaines plus tard que
en Angleterre ce mythe va ensuite
prospérer s'embellir si j'ose dire il va
entrer en résonance avec d'autres
éléments conspirationnistes ça existe
des labètes mais les Juifs la théorie du
complot des Juifs la théorie du complot
des francs-maçons et la théorie du
complot des protestants en tout cas
c'est les trois premières premiers
éléments qui viennent nourrir la théorie
de la conspiration Illuminati tout à
fait vous évoquiez les francs-maçons
alors que les francs-maçons du 18e
siècle sont tout à fait légalistes sont
tout à fait respectueux de l'ordre
social culturel et religieux mais on va
dire que les francs-maçons ont été les
idiots utiles des Illuminati parce que
c'est eux qui l'ont donné le nombre
puisque la société maçonnique est
extrêmement développée au 18e siècle
partout on va dire aussi que finalement
enfin au départ c'est un courrier des
lecteurs qui est adressé à la Barruel
d'un certain Simonini qui lui dit en
fait mettre votre livret extraordinaire
vos mémoires pour écrire l'histoire du
jacobinisme mais vous oubliez vous
oubliez les Juifs et il lui dit moi je
les ai rencontrés à Livourne le fameux
port franc d'un Méditerrané à cette
époque là et c'est eux qui sont derrière
et vous pouvez même ajouter les
Templiers parce qu'au début du XVIIIe
siècle au début de la révolution on fait
resurgir ce mythe templier et Jacques de
Molay qui se serait pas contenté de
jouer au Gémon
[Musique]
sont au cœur
du jeu Rayana devient Princess of vie
Illuminati dans le dernier opus Marvel
Docteur Strange et jugé dans l'espace
par un tribunal illuminatif il n'y a pas
de limite à l'imagination et au fantasme
Jean-Noël comment expliquer vous que
cette façon de de comprendre le fait
social de lui trouver une causalité
maléfique et recueilli une telle saveur
je pense qu'une racine essentielle c'est
c'est un désarroi d'un certain nombre
d'intelligences devant la complexité des
choses et d'autre part et d'autre part
le désir de simplifier la réaction
hostile à des événements qui vous
paraissent de worldworter changer votre
vie ou à la rencontre de cela se dessine
en effet cet objet passionnant pour
l'histoire quel est le complot j'observe
que il y a eu des complots dans
l'histoire des conjurations Jules César
n'est pas là mais on pourrait lui
demander effectivement ce qu'il en pense
puisque une conspiration qui a
fonctionné mais enfin ce qui nous
intéresse ici c'est évidemment la donnée
de la ce qu'on appelle autrefois la
conspiration et maintenant le complot
quelqu'un a dit une idée fausse c'est un
fait de vrai en histoire mais défaut
c'est un fait de vrai ça s'applique
extrêmement bien c'est du des données ça
devient un ressort de l'histoire
l'histoire méconnue mal compris les gens
devient à son tour effectivement
un élément qui va dessiner l'histoire et
par conséquent c'est un objet pour nous
qui sommes des ogres du passé un objet
essentiel mais ce qui était étonnant si
on s'y intéresse de manière ingénue
c'est que on aurait pu imaginer que
l'accomplissement de la société
démocratique met un terme il a mis un
terme aux conspiration parce qu'il a
organisé les parties la vie démocratique
l'élection la sanction des gouvernants
il a créé de la transparence dans
l'exercice du poids et puis par ailleurs
la société démocratique a développé
l'éducation elle a développé
l'information et non seulement ça n'a
pas mis aux théories du complot mais on
a le sentiment qu'elle connaît une
recrudescence très forte à l'époque
contemporaine donc pourquoi est-ce que
la société démocratique n'a pas aboli la
conspiration ou le conspirationnisme
alors que tout tout
en elle travaillait à expliquer le fait
social par ses racines réelles je crois
qu'il faut aller suivre deux pistes
d'abord la complexité accrue du monde
dont on a mieux conscience que quand
chacun vivait dans un dans un décor
plutôt
limité et puis d'autre part évidemment
l'arrivée des moyens de communication
qui sont d'une extrême diversité
autrefois il y avait même en démocratie
des lieux où on émettait des récits des
vérités affirmées les informations peu
nombreux et en gros assez bien contrôlé
même en démocratie et à présent vous
avez une myriade de lieux d'émissions
d'information et par conséquent tout
naturellement il se
absolument à la diversité des
personnages de l'action des personnages
que qui vient d'être évoquer de
l'intervention de ceux qui viennent de
bonne foi ou de mauvaise foi nous
affirmer que le monde très complexe peut
s'expliquer par le fait que quelque part
il y a un petit groupe de gens qui avec
un œil aigu et un cœur sec tire les
ficelles de l'autre pauvre humanité
alors là je m'adresse davantage à
l'ancien ministre qu'à l'historien
devance devant les ravages du
conspirationnisme on l'a vu aux
États-Unis mais on le voit aussi dans
notre pays ne vont l'effet délétère que
cela produit sur l'opinion publique sur
la conscience publique est-ce que vous
imaginez qu'il y ait des moyens d'agir
plus efficaces que ce que nous employons
aujourd'hui j'en vois deux d'abord que
dans les sociétés démocratiques il est
du devoir des responsables politiques et
des responsables des de ces sociétés des
plateformes etc de prendre conscience de
leur extrême
responsabilité à cet égard
entraîner les populations dans des rêves
des fantasmes qui peuvent devenir à leur
tour on le voit bien aux États-Unis tout
à fait tout à fait délétère c'est c'est
une pseudune nécessité plus l'autre
domaine c'est toujours la même chose
enseigné enseigner enseigner de venir
expliquer au futur citoyens au futur
citoyennes qui sont devant eux que le
monde c'est compliqué et qu'on peut pas
aller chercher par une espèce de confort
méphhéique une explication unique à la
diversité des choses
Pierre-Yves lorsque vous enseignez
j'imagine que ce livre a fait l'objet de
cours dans dans l'université comment
réagissez vos étudiants alors évidemment
c'est un échantillon très particulier de
la population tout à fait alors ce qui
est tendance c'est que
je l'invoque plutôt en master pour
tester un certain nombre d'hypothèses
etc parce qu'en première année les
étudiants sont encore tellement marqués
par justement l'emprise de ces
références qui sont désormais le fait
systématique
lorsque les collègues du second degré au
collège et au lycée évoquent les
lumières on leur envoie les
francs-maçons les Illuminati etc parce
que moi quand j'avais 15 ans on ignorait
on ignorait tout de leur existence c'est
devenu omniprésent donc il y a un
travail de déconstruction mais qui
doivent se faire vraiment étape par
étape et comme le disait le président
Jeannet je pense que ça c'est vraiment
important il y a la dimension
d'éducation et importante mais sans
argument d'autorité sans dire aux gens
qui qui croient aux tests complotistes
de toute façon vous n'avez rien compris
etc parce que l'histoire montre qu'en
réalité ça traverse toutes les
générations tous les niveaux culturels
et on le voit bien dans les crises
récentes que vous avez évoquées pandémie
etc et donc il faut qu'on il faut
essayer de démonter ça en comprenant
qu'en réalité esime que désormais
l'esprit critique c'est eux
qui le développe est en proposant des
narratifs alternatifs etc et que nous
finalement on n'a rien compris aux
choses donc il faut ce il faut prendre
l'adversaire au sérieux et arriver mais
c'est compliqué à essayer de prendre en
défaut la cuirasse son argumentaire des
parallèles un peu rapides etc et puis
leur montrer voyez ces documents là ont
été manipulés etc pour ça que moi je
fais souvent des présentations pour les
élèves du collège du lycée parce que il
y a tout un travail de formation du
citoyen qui a un phénomène de il faut
réapprendre à esprit critique parce que
tous ceux qui sont des tenants plus ou
moins avérés des tests complotistes en
reversant les valeurs on considérait
désormais que c'est eux qui incarnent
l'esprit critique donc là il y a
vraiment plutôt que d'invoquer les
lumières une manière très générale il y
a vraiment un travail de terrain à faire
et il est loin d'être gagné évidemment
les clés difficulté de du dialogue avec
les conspirations c'est que nous sommes
nous-mêmes la preuve de ce qu'ils
avancent les tests que nous défendons
nous-mêmes sont l'effet de la
conspiration à laquelle nous appartenons
et s'il n'y a pas de signe c'est bien la
preuve de leur capacité à nous à cacher
les réalités que même veulent affirmer
l'absence de preuve et la preuve que la
thèse est fondée c'est ça qui est
épouvantablement périlleux on va
poursuivre cette conversation avec un
jeune lecteur David qui va je crois vous
poser une question monsieur le
professeur David on vous écoute
[Musique]
bonjour Denis bonjour monsieur
Beaurepaire je me présente je suis David
Lebourg étudiant en 3ème année de
licence de l'être à l'université
d'Orléans donc moi je suis un lecteur
intéressé plutôt par des ouvrages qui
nous poussent à la réflexion donc je
vais être assez friand de tout ce qui
est essais conte philosophie roman par
exemple avec des auteurs comme Kafka
Kundera toutes les bistrots Vercors
entre autres et si je devais raconter un
moment de ma vie de lecteur qui m'a
marqué c'est donc j'ai cité Vercors je
suis très fan de cet auteur et je me
suis mis en quête de rassembler tous les
toutes les œuvres de son corpus et j'ai
trouvé donc un de ses essais sur une
brocante
et j'ai eu la bonne surprise de
découvrir qu'il avait été signé de sa
main voilà donc très bonne surprise ce
petit achat monsieur Beaurepaire à la
lecture de votre
[Musique]
intéressantes du Mas soit intéressé à
kaliostro le chef des illuminés ou qu'on
est encore à somberto Eco et Balzac
histoire des 13 exactement et plein de
de complots
exactement et aux États-Unis en 1801 le
premier roman dit néo-gothique c'est
Julia et le baron Illuminati donc vous
voyez que Dan Brown a eu de très
nombreux prédécesseurs qui étaient
beaucoup plus doués que lui mais je
pense que c'est une très bonne question
parce que on voit justement tout cet
univers dystopique
que vous venez d'évoquer
ça alimente et nourrit aussi
les thèses d'un monde alternatif d'une
d'une autre façon de raconter l'histoire
et puisqu'on évoquait précédemment la
multiplication des réseaux de
communication et des vecteurs de
communication il y a aussi le fait que y
compris dans ce qu'on appelle la bulle
ou la sphère complotiste vous pouvez
avoir en fait vous pouvez tourner en
vaselot sans avoir plus du tout déco ou
de dialogue avec ce qui se passe en
dehors et vous dites vous vous avancez
cette thèse là mais moi j'en avance une
autre j'ai beaucoup plus d'éléments
parce qu'en fait je peux tout mettre
tout relié et donc c'est parfait alors
cette émission malheureusement s'achève
ce n'est pas du tout l'effet d'un
complot c'est et contrainte de la
diffusion mais avant qu'on ne nous
quittions je voudrais que nous
partageions avec ceux qui nous ont fait
le plaisir de nous suivre les un goût de
lecture un livre que vous avez envie de
partager avec eux attention c'est
satisfait ou remboursé il faut qu'il
soit très très heureux du choix que vous
allez leur proposer monsieur le
Président Janet quel est le livre que
vous recommandez je rappelle qu'on a
posé une fois cette question générale de
Gaulle vous voyez ce qu'elles hospites
je me place et qui a répondu c'est le
dernier livre que j'ai lu le livre que
j'ai ouvert hier avec un grand bonheur
mais je l'ouvre souvent c'est
l'anthologie de la prose qui a rédigé
qui a publié Suzanne Julia après une
anthologie de la poésie mais il y a plus
d'anthologie de la PO de la pause qui
est magnifique à laquelle volontiers je
renvoie nos auditrices et nos auditeurs
nous spectateurs et spectatrices
l'anthologie de la peau c'est une idée
originale
monsieur le professeur monsieur
Beaurepaire moi je citerai le cimetière
de Prague d'Umberto Eco qui fait le lien
justement entre histoire et littérature
dans la conspiration puisque je vais
tricher puisque notre lecteur vient
d'évoquer les bistrots la biographie de
Claude Lévi-Strauss part Emmanuel loyer
c'est une merveille l'écriture oui
j'approuve je vous arrête là alors à la
rédaction de
au bonheur des livres nous avons choisi
Jean-Baptiste Naudet seule face au
Führer c'est un journaliste du qui était
au monde au Nouvel Observateur et qui a
entrepris de faire c'est son deuxième
ouvrage de faire le récit de ceux qui
ont tenté d'assassiner Hitler des loups
solitaires là en l'occurrence c'est un
ébéniste qui en 1938 à monter une
machine infernale qui a malheureusement
échoué et il pas s'il refait l'enquête
il l'avait déjà fait à propos d'un
Suisse qui avait pisté Hitler dans toute
l'Allemagne et c'est passionnant Inès
Weber être soi Inès Weber et psychologue
et c'est un essai brillant elle
s'interroge sur la question de savoir
comment cette injonction moderne
Nietzsche devient toi-même devient ce
que tu es et en fait une injonction qui
conduit pas forcément au bonheur et elle
essaye d'expliquer pourquoi parce qu'il
y a plusieurs façons d'être soi il y a
une façon matérielle d'être soi c'est
celle vers quoi on nous conduit c'est le
bonheur matériel mais qui n'est pas
satisfaisant et il y a une façon
spirituelle d'être soi à quoi elle nous
invite absolument passionnant Perrine
nahoun Simon Nahum pardon c'est une
professeure de philosophie à l'École
normale supérieure de la rue d'Ulm elle
se penchant une question qui ne
travaille tous
est-ce qu'on est capable de réactiver la
démocratie est-ce qu'on est capable de
défendre la démocratie contre ces
contenteurs et au fond sa thèse qui est
assez originale c'est de dire qu'il faut
non pas essayer d'effacer ces faiblesses
mais rappeler comment ces faiblesses le
ton long le consensus la difficulté à
trouver les bonnes solutions et de la
force de la démocratie par rapport à
tous les autres régimes et enfin
marque Nexon je sais pas comment on
prononce journaliste au Point
spécialiste de l'ex-URSS et qui part
d'un récit vrai une aéroport
la frontière de l'Arctique qui était
déshérité perdu oubliés par le système
soviétique et dans lequel restaient les
derniers soviétiques alors que l'Empire
avait disparu et à travers ce récit il
refait l'histoire de l'attachement des
citoyens soviétiques
au système si décrié et si légitimement
décrié c'est un peu à la toute autre
manière comme l'homme rouge qui a qui
est par le prix Nobel de littérature
c'est revenir sur
ce qui a fait tout de même un ciment
sentimental des citoyens soviétiques un
régime qui était par ailleurs un régime
de terreur
voilà je vous offre celui-ci je suis sûr
qu'il va vous intéresser merci de
monsieur le Président la démocratie
c'est votre sujet et c'est une autre
mais je vous offre celui-ci aussi
celui-là je le garde pour moi voilà
cette émission est terminée merci
Monsieur bourrepaire Merci monsieur
Janet merci à David notre lecteur merci
à vous tous qui nous avait suivi vous
pouvez revoir cette émission sur la
plateforme numérique de Public Sénat
public sénat.fr ou bien et pas ou bien
et nous nous retrouvons la semaine
prochaine à la même heure à moins que
d'ici là nous ne nous soyons croisés
dans une librairie merci et bonsoir
[Musique]
publique Senna en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres